Quentin Tarantino is keen on taking the
Star Trek franchise to a place it's
never been before but one person is
apparently throwing off his group
someone who apparently doesn't get what
Tarantino was hoping to do with this
Star Trek film is Simon Pegg whom
Tarantino fired a public shot at in a
recent interview with deadlines
Tarantino got to talking about his in
the work Star Trek film for which he has
a very specific vision as his standard
for the violence and vulgarity favouring
filmmaker he wants it to be r-rated and
every bit is bold and bombastic as his
past works
Tarantino got candid when he shared that
he gets quotes annoyed at Simon Pegg for
comments the actor and filmmaker has
previously made about the potential Star
Trek project Pegg of course is known for
his role in the Star Trek reboot
franchise as USS Enterprise engineer
Montgomery Scott aka Scotty a role
previously made iconic by also not
Scottish actor James Doohan in addition
to playing the new Scotty Pegg is also
an accomplished screenwriter who
co-wrote the previous Star Trek movie
2016 Star Trek Beyond with writer Doug
young since then he's been asked on
multiple occasions about Tarantino's
potential involvement in a new Trek film
and his comments have apparently rubbed
Tarantino the wrong way not mincing
words he told deadlines he doesn't know
anything about what's going on and he
keeps making all these comments as if he
knows about stuff one of the comments he
said he's like well look it's not going
to be pulp fiction in space yes it is
Tarantino went on to claim that he has
yet to encounter a science fiction movie
that approaches the material with his
particular style or what he calls quote
that pulp fiction II aspect Pegg made
the pulp fiction and space comment in
May 2000 a teen during an interview with
coming soon in context Peg's remarks
were far from critical he said of
Tarantino's potential movie everyone
sort of assumes it's going to be like
pulp fiction and space but I think his
devotion to Trek and his understanding
of it it won't be ordinary
it'll have him all over it but it won't
be anything a Star Trek fan will have to
worry about Pegg went on to note that at
the time he had not yet read Tarantino's
treatment for the film Pegg also made
comments about the film a few months
earlier during a red carpet interview
with the outlet hey you guys in March
2018 on that occasion Pegg pushed back
against the idea that Tarantino Star
Trek would be r-rated as well as the
idea that he would even be writing the
project himself at all
if it's not heard I think he's written
an r-rated star a Star Trek script I
think what happened is he he went to JJ
with an idea that he's had for a while
so I don't know much about it other than
the fact that it's um it's sort of in
the mix it seems like Tarantino is
expressing his annoyance not because of
the content of pegs remarks but because
he's been on record speculating about it
at all which is an understandable
position to take but in pegs defense
there is a lot of ambiguity and
uncertainty surrounding the Star Trek
flick in question including whether
Tarantino will even direct it which
actors might board to reprise their
roles when it would be released what the
story will be and if it will serve as
the fourth Star Trek film in the new
continuity or a separate entry into the
franchise entirely for Tarantino's part
he made it clear to Deadline that a
final decision on his involvement in
making a movie is still very much to be
determined though the project is being
worked on he said I will say one thing
about Star Trek that have been waiting
for someone to bring up I don't know if
I'll do it or not I've got to figure it
out but marquel Smith wrote a really
cool script I like it a lot there's some
things I need to work on but I really
really liked it Tarantino isn't known
for skirting around profanity or
violence and he's made it clear that if
he's going to do Star Trek he's going to
do it his way no matter what anyone has
to say about it
if you've seen my 9 movies you kind of
know my way is an r-rated way in a way
that is without certain restrictions so
that goes part and parcel I think it
would be more controversial if I said
I'm going to do a PG movie and it's
going to fit exactly in the universe in
the deadline interview the filmmaker
also made a somewhat controversial
statement of his own asserting that as
long as Paramount likes the idea and the
script they've almost got nothing to
lose right now when it comes to Star
Trek it's hard not to read that as
potentially being a shot at the current
state to the franchise which is
floundering on the big screen though it
was previously reported that a fourth
movie in the film franchise would be
going forward centering on James Kurtz
relationship with his father George
played by Chris Hemsworth in the 2009
Star Trek that movie ended up being
cancelled allegedly over contract
negotiations with a cast that felt
through either way the fate of the Star
Trek film franchise remains very much in
the air and it's possible we won't get
any new movie in the series Tarantino or
no for quite some time but if the
reservoir dogs' filmmaker does get
behind the camera for its you can
packed a whole lot less lens flare and a
whole lot more of well stuff like this
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]